world champion magnus carlsen with
Maurice after a titanic struggle where
the blow looked like it was coming but
didn't happen Magnus tell us what
happened his game well I mean first I
was slightly better than he missed was
94563 trick and then I felt that I was
close to winning but I I miscalculated
like I saw my intuition told me to go
after six before 94 then I mean I only
saw afterwards how to refute knight
Knight a5 Knight f5 yeah so I mean if
I'd seen that immediately then I'm not
sure with 95-year referring to well f6
Knight a5 o f6 95 I switch me sorry
instead of you know but the thing is
yeah I mean after after I mean I mean it
felt like it must be winning at that
point but I was absolutely sure it was
winning but then yeah I mean I missed
this and then after Knight g98 I thought
it was all really difficult to find
something the problem is so awesome in
all my games I'm not being a nothing
practical I'm just I just can't make up
my mind I kind of follow my intuition
make decisions so so it's it's it's
frustrating for for sure that's the
interesting thought well you this is
something that you've noticed as a
pattern you know it's just yeah I mean
particularly today was not a good thing
like I drove his father's not a disaster
but I I mean I I got serious chances and
I really couldn't couldn't calculate was
there any effect from yesterday the
crazy game that you were in trouble in
managed to come back no emotional
residue no I mean
you go on to the next it's happy just
happy to survivin and Darren obviously a
lot of was at stake today so it was a
bit nervous but yeah
all right well two games left to help
you clear your mind and good luck in the
rest of your games